whoo great hike today buddy now let's  come up that last hill  and i turned around and you were nowhere  to be found  i thought i was gonna have to go back  and get you well at least we made it  oh yeah i forgot to tell you i uh i i  talk in my sleep  oh yeah quite a bit actually so um if it  bothers you just  uh wake me up okay buddy oh  goodnight good night  [ __ ] your stupid dick  head  jordan let's go camping come on jordan  keep hiking we're almost there oh  buddy so much [ __ ] energy  shove that cliff bar up your ass you  bald sucker  you keegan hyphen  michael key jordan  wake up you're talking in your sleep not  asleep yet  oh nature's gonna be so great once we  get shoved nature  up your ass you bald sucker and by bald  sucker i mean you suck bald  still awake